dustin hoffman once tried to keep things
real
really real by making fun of his
co-star's dead boyfriend and slapping
her in the face allegedly if that wasn't
shocking enough his co-star was meryl
streep
naive daddy's girl baby and macho dancer
johnny are not immediately in sync when
they first meet in the 1987 smash hit
dirty dancing she thinks he's rude he
thinks she's immature this matched the
tone of the relationship between stars
gray and swayze off screen too swayze
later told the american film institute
that much of the film's training montage
was taken from sessions in which swayze
a trained dancer really was trying to
teach grey the right moves all that
frustration on his face is pretty much
real gray later described their
relationship on the dirty dancing set as
a very complex dynamic it didn't help
that the two had previously spent eight
weeks in a military training camp
preparing for their roles in the world
war three movie red dawn gray felt
swayze took his group leader role too
seriously in that production ordering
everyone else around when she was cast
in dirty dancing she even secretly hoped
he wouldn't get the part of johnny i'll
never be sorry
[Music]
neither will i
however the two ultimately found a level
of professional respect gray appreciated
that swayze promised he would protect
her which helped the nervous actress
through their big lifts and to afi
swayze described gray as one of the most
gifted actresses around he added that's
what made her character really really
special
shakespeare once wrote that the course
of true love never did run smooth and
neither did the relationship between the
two actors who brought one of his
greatest plays to the screen claire
danes was only 17 when she appeared in
boz luhrmann's 1996 shakespeare adaption
romeo and juliet her co-star leonardo
dicaprio meanwhile was 21. however danes
was said to be put off by what she saw
as dicaprio's immaturity particularly
the pranks he would pull on the cast and
crew
between takes they totally ignored each
other
dicaprio maintained his prankster
reputation after moving on to play a now
equally famous star-crossed lover during
production on titanic he and his co-star
kate winslet even bonded over pranks as
dicaprio's titanic co-star billy zane
put it if he wasn't rolling back his
eyelids he was making objeddar out of
bodily fluids
while winslet apparently found this
hilarious danes had had more than enough
after the romeo shoot ended she was even
approached to star and titanic opposite
dicaprio but turned the part down she
later claimed that she wasn't ready for
the attention such a big project would
bring
there may have been more to those
awkward silences than hatred however
miriam margulies who played juliet's
nurse has since claimed that danes had a
big crush on her older co-star who
handled it insensitively and simply
tried to stay away from her
although it takes a world war and a
broken engagement for the central couple
in the notebook to get together for good
the sparks between noah and ali are
immediate unlike their characters
however it took years for the actors to
fully warm up to each other neither
rachel mcadams nor ryan gosling were the
studio's first choices for their roles
their chemistry helped them land the
parts but it didn't guarantee an easy
shoot director nick cassavetes later
recalled that while they were shooting a
big scene with lots of extras gosling
asked him to have a different actress
stand out of shot and read mcadam's
lines he allegedly said i'm just not
getting anything from this
cassavetes ultimately pushed the pair to
resolve their conflict for the sake of
the shoot by letting them air their
respective issues in a shouting match
cassavetes remembered the rest of the
film wasn't smooth sailing but it was
smoother sailing the notebook was
released in summer 2004 and became an
instant classic by 2005 gosling and
mcadams weren't just on speaking terms
they were officially dating for real
that year they even won the mtv movie
award for best on-screen kiss for that
rain-drenched moment in the notebook
goslings and mcadams romance ended in
2007 however and it sounded stormy to
the bitter end gosling told gq we both
went down swinging and we called it a
draw
despite spending much of the late 90s
and early 2000s as the go-to charmingly
bumbling rom-com hero there's no love
lost between hugh grant and most of his
co-stars grant himself once freely
admitted on an episode of watch what
happens live
no i'm a nasty piece of work and i think
people should should know that
grant's self-awareness about his
real-life negative effect on women
potentially peaked in an interview with
elle in 2009 as to give three adjectives
about several of his former co-stars he
said that julianne moore rachel weiss
and drew barrymore loathe despise and
hate him respectively grant added
another name to that list in 2015 on
watch what happens live too
saying that julia roberts might also
hate him because i've probably made too
many jokes about the size of her mouth
at least one person appears to have
forgiven grant's rudeness however
although grant made barry moore cry on
the set of music and lyrics he guested
on her talk show in 2021 during this
segment they revealed that a few years
after the movie had come out they had
accidentally made out in a new york
restaurant
seth rogen and catherine heigl got on
well during the filming of their
unplanned pregnancy comedy knocked up
rogan even said on a 2016 edition of the
howard stern show as we were making the
movie honestly i was like i would make a
dozen movies with her heigl had a
slightly different take though her
problem wasn't with rogan but with
aspects of the character she was playing
an uptight career-driven reporter who
gets pregnant after a one-night stand
with a slagger played by rogan heigl
told vanity fair that she disliked that
knocked up paints the women as shrews as
humorless and uptight and it paints the
men as lovable goofy fun-loving guys she
added that the movie was definitely a
little sexist if this had happened today
heigl's comments might be praised but in
2008 she was branded as ungrateful rude
and difficult rogan described her
comments as crazy and said he was
disappointed not to get an apology
although heigl had publicly apologized
in 2016 heigl said again that she
regretted the comments and that she
would work with rogan if he wanted to
work with her a few months later rogan
publicly revealed that he no longer held
a grudge against her
when hollywood newcomer sean young was
cast in the sci-fi epic blade runner she
hoped that her co-star harrison ford
would offer her some support after all
ford was already a household name thanks
to his roles in star wars and raiders of
the lost ark young was especially
looking for guidance during the pair's
love scene however she later recalled
harrison wasn't particularly generous
that way the scene between yong's
replicant rachel and ford's replicant
hunter rick deckard was so violent that
the crew referred to it as the hate
scene it wasn't just ford that young
took issue with on the blade runner set
she later told the daily beast that
director ridley scott deliberately shot
their sex scene in a way that heightened
young's discomfort because she'd
rejected his advances she said i think
it was ridley's none too subtle message
that he was getting even with me their
bad blood came to the fore again in 2017
when young's part in the sequel blade
runner 2049 was limited to a 30-second
appearance as a hologram
imagine landing your first lead role in
a romantic comedy opposite one of the
most famous actresses of the moment then
you get to set and find out from her
that she didn't want you to get the job
jaymore lived that wonderful scenario in
real life when he was cast alongside
jennifer aniston in 1997's picture
perfect on an episode of his podcast
more stories more recalled that the
first scene he and aniston had to shoot
together involved them making out his
first encounter with aniston that day
was when she walked past him with
director glenn gordon karen according to
moore anniston said to karen
six guys they screen test and then she
points at me and goes the one guy i hate
of course the issue may have been that
one of those other guys was aniston's
then then-boyfriend tate donovan moore
said that this animosity continued for
the rest of the shoot he later told elle
that aniston would audibly complain
about him to the other actors in between
takes he said jennifer aniston was so
[ __ ] mean to me that i drove to new
jersey i put my head in my mother's lap
and i [ __ ] cried
just because you're playing soon to be
exes doesn't mean you have to treat your
co-star with x-level hostility
dustin hoffman took his notorious
character immersion too far however
while filming the divorce drama kramer
vs kramer on the movie's shoot hoffman
used real-life bullying tactics to try
to intimidate meryl streep who was
playing his on-screen ex-wife hoffman
and streep got off to a bad start when
they first met at her audition for a
broadway play he was directing whatever
exactly happened hoffman apologized and
streep accepted it but the real trouble
started when the two made kramer vs
kramer hoffman repeatedly made comments
about streep's boyfriend john kazal who
had recently died from lung cancer he
shouted at her when she requested
changes to the script and in a scene in
which the couple is fighting in an
italian restaurant he shocked street by
suddenly throwing a wine glass against
the wall in another fight scene he
spontaneously slapped her across the
face leaving red marks hoffman has
acknowledged that he was venting
emotions brought about by the real-life
divorce he was going through during the
shoot this weak explanation wasn't
helped however when in 2017 multiple
women accused him of sexual assault and
harassment
in breakfast at tiffany's the
relationship between the two
metaphorical drifters holly golightly
and paul varjac sparkles like the
diamonds inside that iconic jewelry
store but off-screen audrey hepburn
found george pipard pompous according to
the movie's co-producer richard shepard
he recalled there wasn't a human being
that andre hepburn didn't have a kind
word for except george pipard
for his part pipar dismissed hepburn as
uptight and prudish calling her the
happy nun as the breakfast at tiffany's
shoot continued pipard constantly tried
to make his character not hepburn's the
center of the movie he refused to take
directions that he thought made paul
unlikable and almost came to blows with
director blake edwards
renowned actor and director lawrence
olivier was initially excited to work
with the superstar marilyn monroe on
1957's the prince and the showgirl he
would be directing and starring opposite
the actress who was fast becoming the
most in-demand woman in hollywood and he
was initially charmed by her too olivier
later recalled when i first met her i
thought she was the most enchanting
thing i'd ever met in my life i thought
she was such a witty actress as well as
being so ravishingly lovely monroe
certainly had a remarkable quality on
screen not just in the way she looked
but in her comic timing too directors
were keen to use that magic and the star
power it afforded her to boost their
projects but the price they paid was
putting up with monroe's maddening
habits she was often laid to set for
example which would hold up the shoot
and whereas olivier was trying to make a
straightforward comedy monroe following
her training insisted on being given a
more intellectual meaning for each line
monroe didn't care for her co-star and
director either she even blamed him for
her lateness saying if you don't respect
your artists they can't work well
respect is what you have to fight for
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]